[Musik]
israel steht unter Schock und alle sind
nervös der unerwartete und brutale
Angriff der Hamas hat einen Krieg
ausgelöst und das ganze Land in höchste
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt nachdem die
israelischen Streitkräfte IDF die
Zivilbevölkerung des nördlichen
gasastreifens aufgefordert haben sich in
den Süden in Sicherheit zu begeben und
einer massiven offensivkampagne der
israelischen Luftwaffe zur Vorbereitung
der bodeninvasion haben die idftruppen
mittlerweile weite Teile des Nordens
besetzt
sie konnten dabei zahlreiche Stützpunkte
der Kamas unter anderem in und unter
zivilen Einrichtungen wie z.B
Krankenhäusern ausheben und viele
Terroristen eliminieren Gaza Stadt wurde
vollständig umzingelt die küstenentklave
in eine Nord und Südhälfte geteilt bei
den Kämpfen sind auf beiden Seiten
zahlreiche Opfer zu beklagen und obwohl
Israel hart gegen die
terrorinfrastruktur der Hamas vorgeht
indem es Tunnelanlagen und Gebäude mit
hamasstellung zerstört gelingt es der
Terrorgruppe nach wie vor und immer
wieder Raketen auf Israel abzufeuern
eine wirkliches Ende des Konflikts ist
nicht in Sicht trotz der Mobilisierung
einer beeindruckenden Streitmacht und
der Überlegenheit in der Luft und
Feuerkraft steht Israel dabei vor der
Herausforderung ihn schnell zu beenden
um weitere zivile Opfer und
internationale Kritik sowie die
Belastung seiner Soldaten zu minimieren
wir reden über ein Militär das etwa 170
reguläre Soldaten hat aber gleichzeitig
eine der größten Reservekapazitäten der
Welt derzeit sind rund 360.000
Reservisten mobilisiert und bereit an
der Seite der professionellen
Streitkräfte zu kämpfen und bei darf
können fast eine halbe Million
Reservisten eingesetzt werden wir
sprechen von normalen Bürgern die in
Israel verpflichtet sind den Wehrdienst
abzuleisten und eine jährliche
militärische Ausbildung zu absolvieren
sowohl Männer als auch Frauen obwohl es
für Frauen mehr Ausnahmen gibt alles in
allem haben sich die israelischen
Verteidigungskräfte den Ruf erarbeitet
eine der besten Armeen der Welt zu sein
laut der eigenen Militärdoktrin stellt
es keine Option da einen Krieg zu
verlieren das pure Überleben des
kleinenhebräischen Staates der von
Milizen und feindlichen Ländern und
Staaten umgeben ist hängt historisch
gesehen davon ab dass seine
Misserfolgsquote gleich Null ist aber
seit der Gründung des modernen Staates
Israel im Jahr 1948 haben sich die
internen und externen Bedrohungen den er
ausgesetzt ist bis heute stark verändert
und mit ihnen haben sich auch die
israelischen Streitkräfte verändert wir
haben schon vor Jahren ein sehr
beliebtes Video gedreht indem wir die
fundamentalen Elemente der israelischen
Militärmacht herausgearbeitet haben es
war übrigens eines unserer ersten Videos
und es war das erste das überhaupt viral
gegangen ist ich werde es Euch natürlich
verlinken denn alles dort Gesagte stimmt
natürlich nach wie vor aber wie sieht es
in den israelischen
verteidigungsstreitkräften heute
wirklich aus wie haben sie sich
verändert und an die verschiedenen
Gegner angepasst und sind sie wirklich
auf das vorbereitet was vor Ihnen liegt
schließlich hat die brutale Invasion der
Hamas am 7 Oktober zahlreiche
schockierende Defizite in der
Verteidigungsbereitschaft Israels
offenelegt und diese Defizite haben
bisher über 1200 unschuldige Menschen
das Leben gek kostet heute werden wir
daher versuchen die brennende Frage zu
beantworten ob Israel tatsächlich oder
nur bedingt abwehrbereit ist hört euch
vorher aber bitte noch das Besondere
Black Friday Angebot unseres tren
Sponsors surfshark an denn solltet ihr
noch kein VPN haben ist dies nun die
einmalige Gelegenheit es so günstig wie
noch nie zu bekommen wusstet ihr z.B
dass viele Firmen wie z.B Airlines ganz
unterschiedliche Preise anbieten können
je nachdem von welchem Land aus man
bestellt bzw ein Ticket Bucht aber zum
Glück kann man solche
diskriminierungsversuche mit Hilfe eines
VPNs überlisten und dann richtig Geld
sparen und surch VPN ist ein wirklich
empfehlenswertes und sicheres VPN
welches z.B keinerlei Verbindungsdaten
mitlockt ein Virtual Private Network
kurz VPN ist aber nicht nur zum
geldparen geeignet denn es kann einen
auch vor so mancher größeren Gefahr
schützen die im Netz lauert natürlich
muss man nach wie vor Umsicht walten
lassen und wissen was man tut aber es
stellt hierfür ein Werkzeug mit gleich
mehreren Vorteilen da zum einen
erschwert es in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktionen im Nest
nachzufolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität im Netz erhöhen
z.B mit dem integrierten cleanwb das
alle unermünschten Cookies und Pop-ups
blockt weiterer Vorteil VPN ist dass ihr
so tun könnt als wärt ihr an einem
anderen Ort so könnt ihr z.B Webseite
und Internetdienste zugreifen die im
Land den wir gerade seid nicht verfügbar
wären ob daheim oder im Urlaub damit
schlagt ihr Zensur und geoblocking ein
Schnippchen Netflix und andere
streamingze die ih Inhalte nur in USA
Anbieten von Europa ausnutzen oder
deutsches Internetfernsehen im Ausland
gucken mit surfshark kein Problem und
das ist noch lange nicht alles den mit
nur einem sur Kol könnt ihr wirklich
alle eure Endgeräte im VP registrieren
Handys noteboxs oder sogar euren Smart
TV so und wenn ihr den Rabattcode
politikde angbt bekommt ihr vzfschlag im
Rahmen des Black Friday special auch
noch zusätzliche se Monate gratis dazu
den Link zu diesem Angebot findet ihr in
der Beschreibung unter diesem Video also
nichts vi los besorgt euch S und greif
damit auch gleichzeitig uns finanziell
unter die Arme das könnt ihr übrigens
auch direkt mit Hilfe des spendenlinks
den ich euch ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung gepackt habe wir sind euch
für jede Unterstützung dankbar denn
damit helft ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch
mehr und noch bessere Videos zu liefern
so und jetzt begeben wir uns auf eine
Reise nach Israel um seine aktuelle
Verteidigungsbereitschaft zu inspizieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aufgepasst die israelischen
Verteidigungskräfte kurz IDF für Israel
Defense Forces wurden offiziell am 31
Mai 1948 gegründet etwa zi Wochen
nachdem der Stad Israel seine
Unabhängigkeit erklärt hatte damid Ben
der israelische Premierminister
beschloss praktisch alle jüdischen
Streitkräfte und militärischen Gruppen
die während des britischen Mandats über
Palästina existierten und die für die
Sicherheit der verschiedenen jüdischen
Organisationen in dem Gebiet zuständig
waren
zusammenzuführen wir sprechen hier von
Gruppen wie der haganali zu dieser Zeit
bereits über Kampferfahrung verfügten
diese Milizen schlossen sich einige
Jahre vor der Unabhängigkeit Israels zu
einer Allianz zusammen die als jüdische
Widerstandsbewegung bekannt wurde und
sich mit den britischen Behörden anlegte
diese Erfahrung war sehr hilfreich bei
der späteren Gründung der IDF die eine
reguläre und organisierte Streitkraft
mit Armee Marine und Luftwaffe sein
sollten diese gerillergruppen haben
zahlreiche Angriffe von Arabern auf
Juden im Mandatsgebiet Palästina erlebt
und darüber hinaus sowohl im ersten als
auch im Zweiten Weltkrieg an der Seite
der britischen Armee gekämpft vergesst
bitte nicht dass Großbritannien ab 1920
die Schutzmacht in Palästina war nachdem
es das Osmanische Reich besiegte das
seinerseits die Region Palästina vier
Jahrhunderte lang fast ununterbrochen
kontrolliert hatte in diesem
Zusammenhang wird davon ausgegangen dass
die ersten jüdischen Streitkräfte der
Geschichte innerhalb der britischen
Armee gebildet wurden nämlich die Jewish
Legion die auch im Ersten Weltkrieg
kämpfte im Zweiten Weltkrieg kämften
dann etwa 40.000 Juden in der britischen
Armee gegen die
Nazis aber wir wollen nicht zu weit
vorgreifen in diesem Zusammenhang ist zu
erwähnen dass die Streitkräfte des
neugegründeten Staates Israel
ursprünglich aus einer kleinen
hochspezialisierten und gut
organisierten Berufsarmee und einer
großen Anzahl von nichtprofessionellen
Truppen bestehen sollten Rekruten die
normale Bürger sein würden aber eine
fortgeschrittene militärische Ausbildung
hatten das heißt wenn jemand Israel
angreift müssen alle oder fast alle
jungen Bürger in der Lage sein zu
reagieren und das ist mehr oder weniger
auch noch heute der Fall allerdings hat
sich seit 1948 bis heute viel getan
damals musste sich das neugegründete
Israel aus dem Stand gegen die Invasion
von fünf arabischen Nationen wehren also
lasst uns doch genau unter die Lupe
nehmen inwi weit sich das Umfeld in dem
sich Israel befindet seitdem verändert
hat
eine veränderte
[Musik]
Bedrohungslage während der letzten 20
Jahre haben sich die Bedrohungen für den
jüdischen Staat dramatisch verändert
seit der Gründung des Staates Israel und
während des größten Teils der zweiten
Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts waren die
Hauptfeinde die eigenen Nachbarstaaten
das waren logischerweise Staaten mit
regulären und professionellen Armeen
Besprechen von Ägypten Jordanien und
Syrien und seit 1979 auch vom Iran in
diesem zusammen Anhang führte Israel in
dieser Zeit mit allen Kriege oder
militärische Auseinandersetzungen mit
einigen wie Ägypten und Syrien sogar
mehr als einmal aber Syrien ist das
einzige arabische Land das sich mit
Israel noch immer im Krieg befindet und
noch keinen Friedensvertrag
unterzeichnet hat um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben Syrien hatte
in den Jahren 48 67 73 und 82 direkte
militärische Auseinandersetzungen mit
Israel in diesem Zusammenhang wurde
Syrien zur einzigen großen Bedrohung
Israels abgesehen vielleicht vom Iran
nach dem Israel Friedensverträge mit
Jordanien und Ägypten unterzeichnet
hatte der Punkt ist dass die
israelischen Verteidigungskräfte
historisch gesehen für eine
konventionelle Kriegsführung ausgebildet
und vorbereitet
wurden diese Ausrichtung änderte sich
allerdings im Jahr 2011 radikal in
diesem Jahr brach nämlich der arabische
Frühling aus der in Syrien zu einem
Bürgerkrieg führte der bis heute
andauert und genau deshalb hat das
alasadreime nicht nur aufgehört eine
direkte Bedrohung für Israel zu sein
nein es kämpft seither um seine eigene
Existenz die syrischen Streitkräfte sind
zerrüttet sie haben nicht einmal die
Kontrolle über das gesamte Staatsgebiet
und zu allem Übel wird die Legitimität
des Regimes mehr als in Frage gestellt
und nicht nur das wie wir euch bereits
in unserem jüngsten Video über die Hamas
und die hesbalah berichtet haben sind
die beiden größten Bedrohungen für
Israel inzwischen nicht staatliche
militärische Gruppen falls ihr es noch
nicht gesehen haben solltet findet ihr
den Link in der Beschreibung es geht
also vor allem um die Hamas und die
hesballah zwei terroristische Gruppen
die vom Iran finanziert ausgebildet und
bewaffnet werden wie ihr euch vorstellt
könnt operieren diese Gruppen nicht wie
reguläres Militär in einem
konventionellen Krieg sondern wenden
asymmetrische Kriegsführung an oder
anders gesagt sie agieren vor allem mit
Terroranschlägen auf israelischem Boden
Infiltration zur Durchführung von
Entführungen Raketenbeschuss oder sogar
cyberkriegsführung und
[Musik]
propagandaaktionen und all das hat dazu
geführt dass die israelischen
Verteidigungskräfte in den letzten
Jahren einen enormen Wandel durchlaufen
haben dies geschah im Wesentlichen im
Rahmen zwei groß Pläne die in diesem
Zusammenhang auch die einzigen sind die
abgeschlossen wurden in diesem Video
werden wir über den größten davon
sprechen den sogenannten gideonpl ein
fünf Jahresplan mit einem Volumen von 15
Milliarden Dollar der den Höhepunkt
eines ganzen Prozesses darstellt mit dem
Israel ein viel kleinere aber
gleichzeitig viel tödlichere Armee haben
will um euch eine Vorstellung zu geben
seit 1985 hat Israel die Zahl seiner
Panzer um 75% und die seine
Kampfflugzeuge um die Hälfte reduziert
vor allem geht es darum ein Militär zu
haben das in der ist Gruppen wie der
Hamas und der hisballah entgegenzutreten
und sie komplett zu
besiegen und im Moment muss die IDF die
Wirksamkeit all diese Reformen mit der
Intervention in Gaza unter Beweis
stellen aber auf jeden Fall hat dieser
ganze Prozess uns von visualpolitik dazu
gebracht uns ein paar Fragen zu stellen
worin genau besteht die Umgestaltung der
israelischen Verteidigungskräfte ist
diese Strategie in ihrer Umsetzung
wirklich so effektiv wie sie uns
verkauft wird könnte Israel in seiner
Verteidigungsdoktrin Fehler gemacht
haben all diese Fragen werden wir es
klären also hör
zu wie ein
Chamäleon der gideonplan wurde 2015
aufgelegt und 2016 vom israelischen
Regierungskabinett genehmigt die Idee
war die israelischen Streitkräfte zu
verkleinern zu modernisieren und zu
reformieren angefangen bei der Anzahl
der
Truppen zunächst wurde die regul Armee
von 45 000 auf 40.000 Mann reduziert
ebenso wie die Zahl der wertpflichtigen
gleichzeitig wurde die wertpflicht um
4er Monate verkürzt und soll den
nächsten Jahren um weitere zwei Monate
reduziert werden sofern sich aufgrund
der aktuellen Umstände nichts ändert
aber wenn etwas gekürzt wurde dann sind
es vor allem die Reservekräfte die um
30% reduziert wurden oder anders
ausgedrückt es wurden etwa 100.000
Reservisten aus dem Dienst
entlassen und das werdet ihr jetzt
wahrscheinlich sehr seltsam finden warum
sollten die israelischen Streitkräfte
die den Streitkräften der Nachbarländer
zahlenm sich weit unterlegen sind
kleiner werden wollen nun das liegt vor
allem an der Annahme einer neuen
Militärdoktrin das israelische Militär
operiert jetzt in viele kleineren
Gebieten als z.B im letzten Jahrhundert
die IDF versuchen nicht mehr Bedrohungen
zu befrieden indem sie ausgedehte
Gebiete in einem feindlichen Staat
besetzen wie es z.B zweimal in Ägypten
geschehen ist das erste Mal 1956 für ein
paar Monate und das zweite Mal 1967 nach
dem sech tagekrieg mit einer Besetzung
die 15 Jahre
[Musik]
dauerte jetzt geht es darum jederzeit
die operative Kontrolle über sehr
begrenzte feindliche Gebiete zu haben um
nämlich Bedrohungen wie den Abschuss von
Raketen oder die Existenz feindlicher
Tunnel auf sehr präzise Weise zu
beseitigen und in diesem Zusammenhang
hat Israel 2011 also noch vor dem Gideon
Plan mit der Umsetzung einer neuen
Doktrin begonnen die auf unabhängigen
Kampfbrigaden basiert damit können die
Brigaden jetzt viel schneller handeln
und außerdem direkt mit der Luftwaffe
und der Marine kommunizieren um
Unterstützung zu erhalten es gibt nicht
mehr so viele Zwischenschritte die
Operationen verzögern diese Veränderung
hat sich natürlich auch auf die
Ausbildung die Bewaffnung und die
Prioritäten ausgewirkt wenn es darum
geht einen Soldaten in ein
einsatzposition zu bringen ihr müsst
verstehen dass Infanterie und
Panzertruppen heutzutage vor allem für
zwei Dinge ausgebildet werden den
stadtkampf und die Zerstörung von
Tunneln und anderen Befestigungen wie
wir euch in den letzten Videos berichtet
haben hat die Hamas eine riesige
Infrastruktur von unterirdischen Tunneln
aufgebaut mit einer Länge von über 500
km dadurch können sie unterirdisch
operieren sich von einem Teil des
Streifens zum anderen bewegen ohne
Gefahr zu laufen draußen bombardiert zu
werden und sie lagern dort auch viele
Waffen wie z.B die berüchtigten Raketen
die sie ständig gegen Israel abfeuern
und diese Tunnel Stellen im Falle eines
urbanen Krieges ein echtes Problem da
erstens weil sie viel schwieriger zu
zerstören sind als ein gewöhnliches
Gebäude in diesem Zusammenhang hat
Israel dafür eine speziell ausgebildete
eliteinheit geschaffen die yahalum
Einheit die über immer mehr Truppen und
Mittel
[Musik]
verfügt diese Einheit ist auf
Infiltration unterirdischen Nahkampf und
tunnelzerstörung alisiert dem
unterirdischen Kampf Mann gegen Mann
versuchen die IDF jedoch nachMöglichkeit
aus dem Weg zu gehen das Risiko oder
Vorteil der Verteidiger sind einfach zu
groß deswegen versucht man vorher alle
anderen möglichen Mittel auszuschöpfen
z.B spongebombs oder eben Bombardierung
aber das Hauptproblem ist dass all diese
Infrastruktur die chamas zu einer
besonders schwer fassbaren Kraft macht
im stadtkampf können chamasgilias und
Scharfschützen von einem Gebäude zum
anderen ziehen und an einen völlig
anderen Ort fliehen um wie aus dem
Nichts aufzutauchen in diesen zammenhang
ist festzustellen dass all diese
kamassoperationen Tunneln und
unterirdischen Befestigungen den Nutzen
der Artillerie stark einschränken dabei
war die Waffengattung V Alben in den
60er und 70er Jahren für Israel
entscheidend jetzt aber ist sie im
Gegensatz zum russisch-ukrainischen
Krieg völlig in den Hintergrund getreten
das Problem mit der Artillerie ist
nämlich dass sie für den Angriff auf
große unbewegliche Ziele im offenen
Gelände konzipiert ist und der Krieg
gegen die Hamas in Gaza ist das genaue
Gegenteil
davon außerdem könnte das große
zerstörungsfeld der Artilleriegeschosse
das Risiko von Beschuss durch eigene
Truppen und von Kollateralschäden an der
Zivilbevölkerung erhöhen auch deswegen
kommt ein massiver Einsatz von
Artillerie nicht mehr in Frage um dem
entgegenzuwirken hat die IDF ihre
Artillerieeinheiten auf spezialisierte
droheneinheiten umgestellt so verfügt
die sigeinheit über Hermes 450 und 900
drohen aus israelischer Herstellung
diese sind äußerst vielseitig sie können
sowohl aufklärungsaufgaben als auch
Aufgaben der elektronischen
Kriegsführung übernehmen und mit
hochpräzisionsraketen angreifen darüber
hinaus gibt es noch eine weitere Einheit
die Skyrider die sich ausschließlich dem
Sammeln von Informationen widmet damit
der Rest der Streitkräfte angemessen
operieren
kann ein großer Teil der Artillerie wird
also durch drohen ersetzt aber das ist
erst der Anfang das israelische Militär
hat begonnen das Thema
cyberkriegsführung und den Einsatz von
Technologie für militärische Anwendung
sehr ernst zu nehmen genau aus diesem
Grund hat der militärische Geheimdienst
am Mann damit begonnen deep learning
Algorithmen einzusetzen die Millionen
und aber Millionen von Daten wie Bildern
Videos Audios und elektronischees
Signale scannen um potenielle Ziele zu
identifizieren diese von den Algorithmen
ausgewählten Ziele werden dann von
Analysten untersucht klassifiziert und
schließlich für tatsächliche Angriffe
bestätigt das macht die israelischen
Verteidigungskräfte enorm effektiv bei
der Ordnung und Zerstörung ihrer Ziele
aber wartet das ist noch nicht alles die
Einheit die für cyberkriegsführung
zuständig ist wurde ebenfalls stark
aufgestockt das geht soweit dass die IDF
ihre alte Doktrin aufgegeben hat nach
der jeder Soldat eine Kampfausbildung
absolvieren muss die IDF rekrutieren
jetzt Soldaten die speziell für die
cyberkriegsführung und
nachrichtendienstliche Aufgaben
zuständig sind ohne dass sie kampfdienst
leisten müssen kurz gesagt all diese
Reformen haben sich in den letzten
Jahren radikal vollzogen Reformen denen
weder die Luftwaffe noch die Marine
entkommen sind die Luftwaffe z.Bp hat
stark an Bedeutung verloren auch wenn
dies in einer Zeit in der israelische
Kampfflugzeuge zusammen mit drohenziele
in Gaza angreifen widersprüchlich
erscheinen mag ihr müsst nämlich
verstehen dass Israel es nicht mehr für
so wichtig hält sich um die Luft
überlegen zu bemühen da der Krieg den es
mit der Hamas und der hisbalah führt
anderer
Mittelbedarf in diesem Zusammenhang hat
die israelische Luftwaffe in den letzten
Jahren Tarnkappen und
präzisionsangriffsfähigkeiten weit über
andere wie z.B Luftkämpfe gestellt das
kommt daher dass weder die Hamas der
islamische dihad noch die hisbalah über
eine Luftwaffe verfügen und es ist auch
nicht damit zu rechnen dass sich dies in
nahe zuurt ändert und genau aufgrund
dieser Tatsache wurde die Luftwaffe
verkleinert aber technologisch stark
verbessert vor allem nach der anchaft
der F35 im Jahr
2015 dieses Kampfflugzeug der fünften
Generation das übrigens nicht für
Luftkämpfe mit hoher Geschwindigkeit
gedacht ist SN sehr weit entfernte Ziele
erreichen und luftbodenangriffe auch mit
Atomwaffen durchführen kann also
aufgepasst Iran und natürlich darf in
diesem Zusammenhang die Marine nicht
fehlen Sehstärke ist für Israel eine
Priorität das Land funktioniert in der
Praxis fast so als wäre es eine Insel
mit anderen Worten 98% der nach Israel
importierten Waren kommen auf dem Seeweg
über das Mittelmeer und mehr als 80% der
Bevölkerung lebt entlang der 197 km
langen Küste außerdem befinden sich die
meisten kritischen Infrastrukturen des
Landes wie Kraftwerke hfen
Entsalzungsanlagen und sogar
Militäreinrichtungen in
Küstennähe das Problem nun die
israelische Marine war ursprünglich
dafür konzipiert der ägyptischen auf der
einen und der syrischen auf der anderen
Seite entgegenzutreten aus diesem Grund
bestand die israelische Marine aus
Zerstörern großen Schiff Raketenwerfern
und U-Booten im Moment scheint es
allerdings eher unwahrscheinlich dass
sich Israel jemals wieder mit
professionellen und gut ausgerüsteten
Seestreitkräften an einem Seekrieg
beteiligen wird vor allem nachdem sich
das militärische Schachbrett nach dem
yomkipur Krieg verändert
hat infolge dessen hat Israel seine
Zerstörer und die größeren Raketenwerfer
durch viele kleinere Patrouillenboote
und kleine Raketenwerfer ersetzt und
viele von euch werden es vielleicht
denken aber ist das alles nicht sehr
riskant schließt Israel einen
konventionellen Krieg in Zukunft
wirklich völlig aus was wäre wenn es zum
Krieg mit dem Iran kommt oder wenn sich
die Beziehungen zu einem Nachbarland
verschlechtern würden nun ihr habt Recht
und glaubt nicht dass viele Dinge von
denen wir euch heute erzählt haben in
Israel nicht auf heftige Kritik gestoßen
wären sogar innerhalb der Streitkräfte
gab es hochrangige Offiziere die einige
dieser Reformen insbesondere den
gideonpl sehr kritisch gesehen haben und
das nicht ohne Grund z.B war der
israelische Marine 2006 im Krieg gegen
hisballa der auf lebanesischem Boden
stattfand nicht in der Lage ausreichende
Unterstützung zu leisten damit ihr eine
Vorstellung davon bekommt worüber wir
hier reden israel hat jetzt sehr kleine
und leichte Schiffe die ideal für die
Bewachung der Küste und gelegentliche
Auseinandersetzung mit boten sind aber
sie verfügen über keinen so starken
raketenschussz die Frage die sich viele
Stellen lautet also könnte es sein dass
Israel sich zu sehr auf die Hamas und
die hisbalah konzentriert und die
Möglichkeit eines konventionellen
Krieges vergessen hat wie genau sieht
die Verteidigungsstrategie aus die sie
in den letzten Jahren verfolgt haben und
die wichtigste Frage von allen
funktioniert sie nun lasst es uns
herausfinden die selbstbefestigung
Israels gegen Ende der 2010er Jahre
änderte Israel seine militärischen Ziele
drastisch es strebte nicht mehr die
vollständige Vernichtung seiner Gegner
an viel mehr wird seit Jahren versucht
größere Konfrontationen zu vermeiden und
ständige aber kleine Operationen
durchzuführen die die Bedrohung auf ein
für die Israelis akzeptables
Gewaltniveau abmildern die Idee war also
sich aktiv zu verteidigen aber
gleichzeitig sich zu Hause zu
verschanzen eine Strategie die als
selbstbefestigung bekannt ist wollt ihr
Beispiele sowohl im Gazastreifen als
auch im Westjordanland gibt es hunderte
von Kilometern befestigter Zeune und
Dutzende von Kilometern an Mauern
Betonmauern wie die an Teilen der Grenze
zum Libanon die 9 m hoch ist oder den
Gaza die 6 m hoch
ist und die sogenannten Israelkritiker
werden nicht müde zu betonen dass diese
Zäune und Mauern dazu dienten die
Palästinenser zu isolieren und eine Art
Apartheit zu errichten nun die Realität
hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun
sondern eher mit Israels neuer
sicherheitsdoktrine in diesem
Zusammenhang können wir feststellen dass
diese Mauern auch stahlverstärkte
Barrieren haben zusätzlich zu der Mauer
die ihr an der Oberfläche seht gibt es
rund um Gase eine unterirdische Mauer
die 65 km lang und bis zu 30 m tief ist
ja ihr habt richtig gehört 30 m
tief darüber hinaus sind die
Landesgrenzen mit Sensoren Alarmsystemen
nachtsichtkameras und einer Vielzahl
andere technischer Geräte ausgestattet
seit 2018 gibt es auch eine seesperre
entlang der Seegrenze des gaserstreifens
mit drei Schichten ein Wellenbrecher
Felsen mit Stacheldraht und jede Menge
Sensoren und Detektoren aller Art und
das alles gibt uns einen Hinweis darauf
wohin die Reise geht all diese realen
befestig des 21 jahrhunderts dieen nicht
dazu die Palästinenser zu isolieren
sondern eher umgekehrt um die Israelis
von Terroristen zu isolieren in diesem
Zusammenhang soll die außergewöhnliche
Höhe der Betonmauern Angriffe von
scharfschüssen verhindern und die
unterirdische Mauer soll verhindern dass
die Hamas aus dem Gazastreifen eindringt
und Angriffe auf Zivilisten verübt oder
diese entführt etwas das übrigens schon
mehrfach passiert ist der Punkt ist dass
all dies auch Teil der neuen Strategie
der IDF ist aber grundsätzlich glauben
viele dass dies keine wirklich
zukunftfähigen weg für Israel darstellt
viel mehr ist es ein Zeichen von
Schwäche je mehr Zäune wir an den
Grenzen errichteten desto mehr wurde
unsere Sicherheitsdoktrin von
Verteidigung und Selbstverteidigung
abhängig eine Gesellschaft die mehr und
mehr Zäune baut ist eine Gesellschaft
die in Angst lebt es mag logisch
erscheinen dass Befestigungen Stärke
vermitteln aber in Wahrheit ist dies
nicht der Fall wenn überhaupt dann
vermitteln sie Angst und angesichts der
Ereignisse vom 7 oktober können wir
eindeutig sagen dass sie ein falsches
Gefühl der Sicherheit erzeugt haben und
dieses falsche Gefühl erklärt dann auch
warum der israelische Geheimdienst
ausschloss dass die Hamas das Land
angreifen könnte und warum das Militär
der Invasion nicht gewachsen war aber
wie konnte die Hamas all diese
Hindernisse überwinden nun alles was sie
brauchten waren ein paar Pickups ein
paar drohen ein paar paragleider mit
Motoren und ein plötzlicher Angriff auf
die von Israel eingesetzten Zensoren und
Technologien das Problem ist dass Israel
wenn wir dies auf die Größe eines
Krieges übertragen den Fehler begehen
könnte sein Militär zu sehr an die
asymmetrische Kriegsführung angepasst zu
haben so dass es auf ein zukünftiges
Szenario der konventionellen
Kriegsführung schlecht vorbereitet ist
das ist zumindest die Sorge die viele
Analysten zum Ausdruck
bringen wer kann ihn schließlich
versichern dass der Iran sie niemals
angreifen wird oder dass einige der
Länder mit denen sie jetzt mehr oder
weniger gut auskommen plötzlich ihre
Haltung ändern und wieder feindselig
werden könnten denn wenn eines klar ist
dann ist es dass wir im Nahen Osten nie
etwas für selbstverständlich halten
können und das ist die große Frage die
sich viele in den IDF gestellt haben
eine Frage die heute angesichs der
äußerst angespannten Lage in der Region
extrem aktuell geworden ist allerdings
können wir diese Frage im Moment noch
nicht beantworten das werden wir in
weiteren Videos tun und bis dahin geben
wir den Ball erstmal an euch weiter was
haltet ihr von den Veränderungen die die
israelischen Streitkräfte durchlaufen
haben denkt ihr dass sie auf dem
richtigen Weg sind oder seid ihr im
Gegenteil der Meinung dass eine solche
Priorisierung der asymmetrischen
Kriegsführung zu einer großen
Sicherheitslücke führen könnte ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like und
teilt es auch mit euren Freunden um es
mit ihnen zu diskutieren mach's gut und
bis
[Musik]
bald